欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天台股真的叫做世界第一强
我们尾盘上涨了820点
距离历史新高
现在只差1200点了
今天的气势从何而来呢
其实有很多事情的加持
昨天晚上我们看到
辉达跟联发科携手开了一个
记者会宣布大事情
回答要投資
這個所謂聯發科的可轉債
高達35億美元
而且Google也有做一些著量的投資
這當然讓今天的發哥一架漲停
但意義不止如此
等一下會來跟各位觀眾解析
這牽涉到台灣晶片股的
十年未來大夢
是非常重要的一件事情
這也激勵掉台股今天的科技股市
全面上漲的一個態勢
所以今天即使雅股的表現不理想
昨天晚上廢半也有壓力
我們卻氣勢如虹
但是我们能够带领着全世界的科技继续往上冲吗
前面会不会有一些挑战跟难关呢
以及明天所谓全世界最大的半导体展
在台湾也要展开了
会带动哪些商机
等一下一件一件跟您说分明
好第一位欢迎我们的AI达人蔡明翰
太开心了看到明翰就想到
未来台湾就有十年的AI大梦继续做下去
一切就源自于昨天晚上
会打跟联发科一起开的合体记者会
黄连勋黄爸爸和这个
我们联发科的执行长蔡立行
一起来跟大家讲未来的蓝图
这到底对台湾整体AI发展
会有多深远的影响
等一下一件一件跟您讲
那至于9月
很多人说9月是一个美股的魔咒月
但是现在有光亮起来了
大力光今天差一点点
就要8000块钱了
带动着整体CPU
最近有很多细光子的论坛
台积电也讲
2027年矽光子的渗透率会高达50%
怎么算的
等一下明汉就联发科跟大力光带动的两大领域
跟您说清楚
好第二位是我们的古奇双分析师
季伟明小明同学
好小明同学也要说半导体就是我们的主场
尤其是这两天半导体展热热闹闹
开展了各论坛一字排开超级强
今天盘面上谁最被低估谁在涨就是设备股
有人接近前高
有人是營收創高位階卻很低未來的肉相當的多等一下告訴你整體看展要看什么还有ASIC相关的到底台湾在ASIC这个自研晶片领域IC设计
能够拿到多少的报单量
等一下小明同学
算给你听哦
好第三位呢
是我们的型男股神
威良哥
威良哥也要提醒大家
前阵子我们听到
大家要什么呢
筹资扩厂
要举债
压力三大对不对
No 错了
我们从发个例子就知道
你今天要發行所謂的籌資
就是為了後面要有更大的股東
後面要有更大的算力
後面要有更大的產能被壓低
絕對都是一個好機會
等一下幫你把整體籌資股的運作講回來
那至於有一檔先前籌資
這兩天有點壓力的叫做星星
星星今天沒有鎖住了
甚至盤中一度要拉到平盤
危機是不是正式解除
等一下吳良哥跟您說
但是如果左眼在剛剛講
籌資為了全球的算力
大家都在講
有沒有什麼樣的商品
一檔全部打包
全球算力
等一下也幫您做介紹
好 首先有請米漢哥
好 今天來的正是時候
昨天晚上出大事了
這個大事是對台灣很開心
對於美股還好
可見得我們對半導體
或是IC這件事情的反應
是極大的
就是輝達買了
發個35億美元的可轉債
並且兩人構築了
台灣晶片十年的未來大夢
等一下來幫大家解釋
9月好像美股的狀況通常不是太好
但是光來了
台積電講說
2027年的矽光子滲透率50%
到底該怎麼買
好 應該這樣講
剛剛趙華提到
今天台灣等於是世界第一強
真的
那重點就是因為揮達
然後投資發歌
然後台灣今天重點在十年大夢
就代表了可能短時間數字還進不來
所以大家可以知道
後面的架構大概長什麼樣子
我們先講一下這個輝達
為什麼要投資聯發科
那這個重點就是39億美元
那應該說佔了整個所謂的
佔比接近九成左右
那記得它的轉換價
就是大概4500
對 然後還有一個重點
除了輝達之外
就是這個TPU的母公司
就是Apple的一個部分
它也有認購
但比例相對來講並不高
那公司有提到他這些
未來的一些購料的需求
鎖定先進製程 先進封裝還有相對需要的AI原物料應該就是未來他拿這筆錢的一個重心回過頭來為什麼輝達要這個投資聯發科
簡單的一個總結
就是不希望聯發科被
這個客製化晶片
ASIC那邊陣營的人給拉走
對 那要就是防禦戰嘛
他就是要反制這些所謂
雲端業者自研晶片
那他要的是什麼
希望聯發科未來走他們的
等於說走輝達的架構
像NVLink希望都走輝達的架構
就在設計上可以一起綁定
那這塊呢
聯發客的部分來講
當然OK啊
反正這個目前來講
輝達的這個規格
就是一個最大的一個市場
另外一個就是產能戰
其實現在比較重要的
就是台積電的產能
現在全球所有晶片都在瓜分他
那輝達該拿的也拿的
可是他應該這樣
他拿夠了之外
應該這樣他也沒拿夠
最起碼他能拿的都拿到了
可是他现在不想要
其他的产能被其他的云端业者拿走
所以当然如果联发科去排队
你缺钱没钱排队
我出钱去排队
不要让他们拿走
那相对来讲呢
当然联发科这样当然是好
因为他现在有产能
难够拿到台积电产能的
就是一个重要的关键
他就是王者
所以另外呢就是资本站
各取所需
另外輝達的部分進可攻退可守
先放在可轉載它有固定的利息
未來股價漲了它又可以轉換
所以幾乎就是穩穩不赔
聯發科的部分
靠著這一段呢
合作的關係
它可以拿到比較低成本的
這個所謂的資金
所以雙面來講都是賺的
我們再講一下
為什麼聯發科可以
這個獲得輝達的相挺
其實比較重要的關鍵
我常常講整個
所謂電子的產品線就像這樣
一開始你公司裡面要有產品的設計
然後自己去做市場的動作
你要產品做出來
自己都覺得對
這個就是市場要的
等到確認之後
再交給客戶下去做驗證
客戶看一看說這個東西不錯
對我未來營運很有幫助
他就會取得訂單
然後訂單再來要找到
這個所謂代工的部分下去量產
最後交給客戶就營收任列
他有這個一定的六個步驟
那我就常講這個步驟
你現在位處在哪裡就很重要
因為你只要越往左邊你的變數就會越大最後要認列營收的機率就會小得非常多為什麼聯發科就是相對來講比較穩健因為他不只是這客戶業者
而且目前已經取得訂單
然後呢
等著年底就可以大量出貨
對比而言
就是聯發科算是今年切入
這個AI很重要的代表的全資股
另外一個市場關注的
就是有光的大力光
他也是要切入這個AI
這兩家以前都當過台股的股王
只是現在當股王不容易了
要萬元以上
但都重返榮耀
都創下歷史新高
應該這樣講
他們兩個有個特色就是
今年已經第三年AI
前兩年業績真的是平的
兩個都在智慧手機
兩個都是平的
一點成長都沒有
所以股價相對是落後的
然後一直到今年
大家都認為
以這個架構來講
他們已經即將要開始
這個實現的AI大夢
那剛剛提到的聯發科是TPU
那大力光是FA
就是要進入這個CPU的部分
那我個人覺得就是
設計他自己的部分已經完成了
所以他才在法說會講到
他們有這個產品
那重點是他們現在正在試產的階段而已
上次法說就提到試產
產出來之後還要送客戶驗證
然後客戶覺得沒問題
而且中間常常知道
有時候看起來對
可能為了這個客戶
還要去修改相關的製程
所以兩個應該說架構都有共通點
就是以前的所謂產業的王者
現在從落後了兩到三年
現在要跨入AI了
但是故事其實還
憑良心講有蠻明顯的落差
好 故事的進展雷同
以前從智慧型手機
現在都踏進AI了
但這個要成真
就是營收要進來
感覺上明年就很有機會發哥
大力光可能他自己有講
2028年才會有相關的
營收大幅的進來
所以這個進程不同
但發哥受到揮答的肯定
世界在跟我們搶人了
這個發哥陣營
揮答陣營跟所謂的ASIC陣營
都要聯發哥
這件事情毋庸置疑
聯發哥今年股價能夠轉強
靠的其實是Google的TPU
那以這次揮答
對於他營收獲利有沒有貢獻
答案是沒有的
但是他只是要告訴大家就是說
其實輝達已經看到
他不希望聯巴科跟他的競爭者走得太密
然後他這一邊呢
〔此段辨識失敗，約 10:00 起〕